monsieur vie philippe vitel pour le
groupe des républicains madame la
présidente
mes chers collègues ma question à
laquelle j'associe ma collègue geneviève
levy s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre
ce premier ministre le budget de nos
armées a été votée hier par la majorité
de gauche de notre assemblée
il ne prévoit qu'une offre de crédit de
600 millions d'euros qui est sans
commune mesure avec les crises que nous
traversons et qui exige de nos armes et
une intensité d'engagement sans
précédent depuis 70 ans
il permet simplement d'éviter la rupture
et la cessation de paiement mais sans
mais en aucun cas de construire notre
armée du futur demain sera voté le
budget des anciens combattants il est en
recul de 125 millions d'euros alors que
la prévision triennal prévoyez 114
ce sont au total 5 144 millions soit
près de 20% du budget qui se seront
bloqués entre 2013 et 2017
la retraite du combattant que nous
avions revalorisé de 11 points entre
2007 et 2012 est bloquée alain 10 48
depuis votre accession aux
responsabilités mais surtout il apparaît
à la lecture des documents que vous nous
avez fourni que vous envisagez de mettre
progressivement sous conditions de
ressources toutes les aides allouées aux
anciens combattants à leurs veuves à
leur conjoint et à leurs ayants droits
évoquant nos anciens combattants
clemenceau prononcé à la tribune notre
assemblée
une phrase restée célèbre ils ont des
droits sur nous il signifiait par cela
que les anciens combattants avait un
droit imprescriptible à réparation
monsieur le premier ministre pouvez-vous
garantir à la représentation nationale
que dans votre esprit
nos anciens combattants ne sont pas des
citoyens comme les autres parce qu'ils
sont tout simplement des anciens
combattants merci monsieur le député
l'appareil avec le secrétaire d'état
chargé des anciens combattants
mémoire oui madame la présidente
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député vistelle jo je vous
remercie tout d'abord de me permettre de
vous répondre aujourd'hui d'évoquer le
budget des anciens combattants que je
défendrai demain devant vous oui c'est
un budget ambitieux résultat de choix
politiques et de choix budgétaires dans
tous cas porteurs de sujets qui nous
concernent tous
vous avez raison sur ce sujet là ce
budget a été construit des engagements
que j'ai pris devant la représentation
nationale mais aussi devant le monde
combattant
les associations d'anciens combattants
qui ont été associés aux travaux
concernant ce budget le budget 2016
préserve et on solide intégralement les
droits des anciens combattants en
maintenant à la fois l'ensemble des
dispositifs budgétaires et fiscaux mais
il va au delà
oui il va au delà en renforçant les
droits des anciens combattants et des
victimes de guerre
dans un souci de justice sociale et
d'équité en se concentrant sur les plus
démunis
il renforce les droits avec une
extension du bénéfice de la campagne
double pour les anciens combattants
d'afrique du nord
cette mesure était attendue depuis 1999
par les actions des associations
d'anciens combattants
nous le ferons et il conforte aussi les
droits avec l'élargissement du
dispositif de la majoration spéciale des
conjoints survivants des grands
invalides
enfin au niveau des crédits sociaux une
augmentation du budget de 2 millions
d'euros porteront la hausse depuis 2002
depuis l'entrée en vigueur de la
nouvelle majorité à plus de 26% à plus
de 26% depuis 2012
c'est cela aussi s'occuper des plus
démunis enfin un nouveau dispositif
verra le jour pour répondre aux
conjoints et conjointes de harkis qui
était touché par la forclusion
concernant l'allocation de
reconnaissance
cela concerne tout simplement le droit
et la reconnaissance de la nation
vis-à-vis d'eux vous le voyez monsieur
le député des anciens combattants sont
au coeur des préoccupations de ce
gouvernement
albert